what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alva here 6 a.m. on a Sunday morning
here to watch the Justice League trailer
and yes today I'm all by myself he said
you'd come now let's hope you're not too
late you told me by by six do you
realize we live together now like you
could you could just knock you think
you're so funny don't you John
alright that intro is done let's watch
this trailer I'm so excited I hope we
see Superman without a moustache oh
right
[Music]
oh yeah we got one yesterday okay that
Louis or Martha
she's all you where's plaid I'm you
favor kind of Electra lacks man Oh
[Music]
holy crap I think it's something more
something darker yeah
[Music]
sweet people we don't know to risk their
lives
[Music]
it's not saying that's the opposite of
what the saying is
[Music]
beautiful
divided we are not enough
[Music]
I'm feeling this nice here look at this
this looks awesome it won't look so
positive
[Music]
your signal that means we have to go now
yeah I think the clucker use ffos clever
use of marketing in terms of the
Superman part you have the big debate
that people have been having are they're
gonna see Superman in action in the
trailer that's what everyone's been
wondering this whole time cavil and they
gave us that without giving us that yeah
because it was a flashback sequence yeah
you know but they really are
capitalizing on the the spirit of
Superman's passing and what he
represented being a yeah so I even
though I feel like Superman I show up a
little late into the film I had imagined
that what Superman stood for will
probably be even felt more with this
league Uniting yeah maybe we'll finally
you know what Superman a real need for
that yeah that was clever use of doing
that all the images of like Steppenwolf
and the parademons look really great to
me it threw me off a tad bit I think I
said like everyone's looking so positive
in the trailer Ninja Turtles I mean the
trailer took time as compared to like
the last couple trailers especially the
comic book one yeah while this show
there was jam-packed with action I
really did feel like it gave us that
they're gonna they're gonna have like
character interaction I felt it slow
down a little bit just enough to feel
like okay we'll have good fun character
scenes it's giving me what I want I feel
like there are people out there will
probably want something that's like much
deeper I know it for you especially we
had this debate last time I agree
however I mainly just want to walk away
with this feeling of that was a lot of
fun and again everyone made me laugh and
smile and I
like a really good energy and I felt
like cheering at times at how cool it
was seeing all these guys fight together
and the more I see you this the trailer
seemed pretty consistent in giving me
that feeling I'm kind of with you on
that I mean I felt some of the
excitement watching this I think it does
look distinct and that's cool to me like
the look yeah of just the the color
palette and the just the visual design
and all that stuff doesn't look like
every other superhero movie I've seen in
recent time so that was cool I liked
their leading with the group's chemistry
together yeah you know it cuz that was
one of my complaints about the earlier
trailers it's like okay I get it action
cool but like what else and I feel like
they're also like they gave Aquaman a
little bit more time to shine in this
trailer - cyborg gotta have that cool
little bonding moment when he's picking
up my man yeah and one thing I feel like
we got a slightly touch on just a little
bit is you know Joss sweet and there's
that how lucky were doing you saw
Rosanna the day came out of how Joss
Whedon got a writing credit for this
film when all he was supposed to do was
handle a little bit of post or like
finish up the post whatever and then
when you get a writing credit though
what I heard I could be wrong but what I
heard is that to get a writing credit
you have to have you have to kill the
OREA to kill the original writer and
take over I heard you have to have
contributed at least 30% somewhere
around there to the screenplay meaning
he did provide a lot of rewrite you get
I don't know with the son the original
script or this is from John I mean this
feels more like Joss Whedon's character
interaction like the visuals and the
action scenes still look like Zak
slander but the character interaction
feels more like John sweet and which I'm
cool with I'm cool with a hybrid like
that I guess one thing the trailer was
lacking for me because well I feel like
it's gonna be that great popcorn fund
that I'm looking to have with this movie
I really feel like these guys don't feel
like that are in danger taking on the
apocalypse right people from a planet
called apocalypse Steppenwolf and
parademons yeah it's like well you guys
seem like really incredibly common this
is the most interesting trailer so far
to me like this hooked me on that level
but it did lose me more on the level you
just touched I was like yeah everyone
looks like there's a psyched to be here
psyched to be doing this and we're all
here crack jokes and so yeah it's just
flirting with that it's your the Justice
League yeah like there's gotta be like
equally thrilling and perilous as fun
it's got to happen it's got to know when
it has to be fun and exciting and a
house
it has to know when it has to be intense
I mean they got this after key Arne
Hines who's a fantastic actor have been
around for decades and you don't really
get it here so open any of these
trailers and he's such a great character
actor that I'm thinking if you got that
guy in there to play Steppenwolf you got
to take advantage of that I would like
to feel a little bit more of the danger
it's just a trailer regardless beyond
those like concerns I still feel like
I'm gonna get what I really just care
about which is walking now going that
was so much fun to be there like Wonder
Woman be the really meaningful moving
picture of the year this one I just care
more about it to being a really big
blast yeah for sure I mean I'm happy to
let Wonder Woman handle that oh I my
heart I just I want it to be more than
just fun okay I I understand I
understand I feel like we've been we've
been trying this for so long they did
have a dark tone set up so you can't
just completely another transition it
that's the issue for I guess for me is
it's hard to acclimate to so I'm like
you guys let every trailer for this
looks like we're having a great time now
guys right at the beginning of this fun
everybody except for at the beginning of
the trailer I was actually drunk that
seeing Lois having that dream about when
Clark proposed to her yeah yeah it was a
cool little reveal and yeah yeah cool
let's just hope we can get a little bit
more of that maybe you know maybe that's
when I'll get more emotional and
Superman sir maybe that's what all the
fun will stop alright guys well what do
you think of the Justice League trailer
are you guys excited for this it comes
out in like a little over a month man
I'm excited ready maybe less than I'm on
the ring get the release date we should
probably you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification bow
follow - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram I'm at the greg alba and check
out our patreon become a patron eject
today and then maybe i'll get some sleep
once this videos up yay
[Music]